hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast anti-nuclear antibody
screening making an informed decision
presented by dr. Gog Abel director of
clinical chemistry and molecular
diagnostics and immunology at Lahey
Hospital and Medical Center and dr.
Melissa Schneider the co-director at the
antibody immunology laboratory at Mayo
Clinic I'm Suzy Valdez elaborates and
I'll be your moderator for today's
events today's educational webinar is
presented by elaborates the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by bio-rad
laboratories bio-rad is a global leader
in the health care industry with
innovative and useful products that help
life science researchers accelerate the
discovery process and the clinical
Diagnostics lab obtained faster and
better results today we are conducting a
few polls throughout the art
presentation we encourage you to
participate and have your input and it's
appreciated the questions will pop up in
the middle of the screen our first poll
of the day is what methods are you
currently using for na-na screening
please check all that apply
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on the green + Q&A button located
at the lower left of your presentation
window type the questions into the box
that appear on the screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation to
enlarge the window just press on that
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation click on the
support button at the top right or use
that Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the seat button at the
bottom left hand corner and follow the
process for obtaining your credits I'd
now like to introduce our two presenters
dr. GOG Abel and dr. Melissa Schneider
first dr. Abel is a director of clinical
chemistry molecular diagnostics and
immunology at Lahey Hospital and Medical
Center and is the instructor in
pathologist Harvard Medical School in
Boston dr. Abel completed his residency
at the Massachusetts General Hospital
and became board-certified in clinical
pathology and in molecular diagnostics
he is a fellow of a acc where he was
recently elected as a council member he
also serves on the diagnostic immunology
resource committee of the cap dr. Abel
is the Past Chair of the clinical
immunology division of the ACC former
vice-president of the American Board of
clinical chemistry and former member of
the clinical immunology committee of the
American Association of immunologists
and please welcome our second presenter
dr. Melissa Schneider dr. Snyder is the
co-director of the antibody immunology
laboratory at Mayo Clinic with an
academic appointment as assistant
professor of laboratory medicine and
pathology dr. Snyder completed her
doctoral degree in biochemistry through
the Myo Graduate School in 1997 she
followed that with a post doctorate
fellowship in clinical and basic
immunology she been completed a clinical
chemistry fellowship at the Mayo Clinic
where she focused on laboratory
diagnostics and autoimmune diseases
after completing her clinical fellowship
she was board-certified in clinical
chemistry by the American Board of
clinical chemistry
throughout her career dr. Snyder has
been active in a number of scientific
societies supporting their efforts to
promote the field of Clinical Laboratory
immunology dr. Snyder is currently the
chair elect of the clinical and
diagnostic immunology division she
also a member of the association of
medical laboratory immunologist and
previously served as a counselor at the
executive committee level
please welcome dr. Abel and dr.
Schneider good morning or good afternoon
depending on your time zone it's my
pleasure to be the presenter at this lab
hoods webinar and would like to thank to
the organizers for the invitation the
anti-nuclear antibody testing is really
topic which is very exciting it
generates a lot of debate and
discussions in the College of American
Pathologists as well at ACC and
professional organizations and this is
an area where we are seeing a change
change coming but still we have the
classic help to sell based in the
fluorescent testing as the dominant form
of ena screening and we do see how this
transformation that is going to happen
or not today we are going to review and
I will stop the general review of any
testing and general review of the
importance of the different antibodies
from the clinical perspective and
learning objectives will be to list the
different methods available to the
clinical laboratory describe the current
A&E testing guidelines and augering and
also learn about the differently any
methods and how they compare in that
aspect actually to be particularly
important to see the Chris Isaak's
presentation because she did a very nice
scientific study in which she and her
co-workers compared various types of
tests let's start with anti-nuclear
antibodies these are either IgG or IgM
in nature it binds the nuclei or nuclear
proteins nuclear components of the cells
as we know these are very harmful they
directly affect your many organs and
attack the nuclear components of many
cells in the body and cause
is autoimmune disorders there are
various screening tests available for
this the most commonly used is a slice
test which uses a fixed and permeable
eyes human help to sell these tests
actually measures the direct binding and
the patient's serum antibodies the same
apply after initial screening the
specific components can be identified
kind of like dissecting the nucleus to
the various components and finding out
which immune assay methods which
component is the one that generated the
antibody which is harmful in the case of
the Pacific's specific patient so this
slide briefly views how the indirect
immunofluorescence essay is performed
and for this we use this happy to help
two cells which have nuclei and the
nuclei contained antibodies they take to
their antigens and after this the
patient serum is overlaid these cells on
the sounds the antibodies if present are
bound to the antigens and following this
and
anti-human IgG is used which is labeled
with fluorescent and the microscopic
examination will reveal whether or not
the first step occurred whether or not
any antibodies were bound to the
antigens
there are several very characteristic
patterns the most one of the most
well-known is the homogeneous pattern
which is a uniform fluorescent staining
in the nuclei as you can see here in
entire nucleus and interphase cells in
this case actually antigen is DNA itself
or DNA histone complex this pattern is
most commonly seen in in systemic lupus
erythematosus this is very specific for
this disease that also can be seen in
drug-induced lupus occasionally
rheumatoid arthritis join ironic
arthritis and systemic sclerosis but
again your SLE is the one where this
particular pattern is very specific if
this pattern is seen then further
evaluation of the different antibodies
definitely includes the anti
double-stranded DNA and the anti Smith's
antibody test which can further reveal
which particular antibody is responsible
for the pattern well your next slide we
can see the so-called rim pattern with
the rim pattern there is a diffuse
nuclear staining however around the rim
of the nuclei you can see a little bit
more intense staining as for example is
seen here or another area right here
also for this pattern the antigens just
like for the homogeneous pattern or the
double-stranded DNA and the DNA histone
complex and SLE is the disorder where
this particular antibody is the most
specific and most characteristic a
commonly seen pattern is the speckled
pattern this is the most common but the
least specific there are different types
and many different types of special
patterns fine or coarse speckles which
are distributed in the entire nucleus
area in interphase cells at least twelve
different antigens are responsible may
be responsible for this pattern
including the nuclear RMP
in the Swiss him ro and le and the
diseases which in in which this pattern
may occur include system it lupus
erythematosus mixed connective tissue
disease system exclusives as well as
children serum when this pattern is seen
it will require further evaluation
including the smiths antibody the anti
RMP the SES 70 the anti row which is the
end Issa in entirely and isis be the
antibody should be individually measured
if this pattern is seen another speckled
pattern is the centromere pattern in
this case we would expect actually to
see like 46 centimeters but these cells
are really not the head two cells are
not quite like the normal human cells
there might be various numbers of
chromosomes and so we can see somewhere
between 40 to 80 discrete speckles just
as seen in these cells these are aligned
in the chromosomal each region of the
mitotic cells the diseases includes
Claro Burma limited scleroderma or crest
syndrome and often these batteries
associated with pulmonary Morman
they are also seen in Reno's new birth
pattern this is also another form of the
speckled pattern but the but a speck of
such a much larger and they are red
clumpy and they stain the nucleus of
interphase cells call it is caused by
various nuclear and Auto antibodies
which include the RNA polymerase 1 2 3 n
type EMS CL also important the u 3r n P
and R NP antigens it can generate elicit
these antibodies the diseases which
include this pattern include caldera and
drain of syndrome and we also show here
a negative staining where we don't see
any staining there are other patterns
which actually not even nuclei or nuclei
rather the ribosomal pattern in the
system it lupus erythematosus with
neuropsychiatric see
we might see ribosomal patterns in the
sight of blood or the Golgi pattern
which is which is occurring in
rheumatoid arthritis
sometimes in SLE cigarettes but also in
patients who have HIV infection so some
sera actually may produce multiple
patterns and the ring pattern might be
seen at low dilution and homogeneous
pattern at higher evolution so this
makes it more difficult for the
investigator to figure out exactly what
is the pattern especially the different
patterns mixed and also it can be found
sometimes that the homogeneous or
peripheral green pattern is seen at low
delusion and the speckled pattern at the
higher dilution or the other way around
so this is not an easy it needs a lot of
experience and knowledge to be a really
good technology store for psychologists
the pathologist who evaluate these
various patterns and there are a lot
more patterns but this is not the goal
of this presentation to go into the very
details of all the patterns that might
be seen with the occurrence of different
antibodies so an ear is screaming the 1
to 40 dilution gives excellent
sensitivity however the specificity is
really not good about 32 percent of
normals including blood donors may have
some degree of staining at 1 to 40
dilution of the serum of this of the
test cell at 1 to 80 if we still are
very close to the sensitivity that we
see at 1 to 40 however there is a
significant reduction in positive
screens you do non-systemic robotic
disease and the normal healthy
individuals at 1 to 160 we see a modest
reduction in sensitivity however this in
this dilution only about 5 percent of
normal healthy individuals will give
some kind of a na pattern it 1 2 3 xx
would eliminate most false positives
however there is a drop in the
sensitivity still this is used by some
manufacturers
standard cutoff for IFA and normal titer
is considered unless the de- less than
one 240 dilution however the cutoff
depending on the manufacturer and
depending on the laboratories experience
may be increased up to one to 160 where
you do your cutoff positives again up to
30% of the patients may have some kind
of staining with this method it is more
common in older women and also the
system agrammatic diseases of course you
see staining system in Cooper's
erythematosus but also with rheumatoid
arthritis and mixed connective tissue
the disappearance necrotizing maskel IDs
positives are seen in diseases which are
actually not autoimmune in nature in
tuberculosis correct active hepatitis
and the quadratus various types of
infections but also in diabetes multiple
sclerosis and others it has been debated
whether these antibodies are real in
silicone gel the breast implants it that
has been in the literature that that has
been debated whether those actually
elicit out in the antibodies and of
course there is an entire slew of
medications that may induce Auto
antibodies which cross-react this is
seen in drug-induced SLE if I tell or
antibodies if they are at the titer of
less than 1 to 80 they are likely not
significant but if they are over 1 to 3
20 they are highly significant most
likely and the interpretation it goes
together with the pattern as I mentioned
already homogeneous and rim patter and
the scene with SLE scale them and ladies
curve there ma may give a Nuke lower or
centromere pattern but the least
specific pattern is a speckled pattern
because it's kind of hard to say which
exact disorders behind the speckle
pattern the dermatologist really need to
use their clinical judgment and other
laboratory findings to figure out what's
going on if there
like a low titer speckled pattern often
times those are meaningless briefly bar
disease associations and be patient it
has an SLE with the well-known butterfly
rash as you can see around the nose and
on the face this is the butterfly
pattern rash seen in SLE very commonly
very important that in systemically
besides the mitosis in 99% of the cases
days some kind of an anti-nuclear
antibody and there are a number of
clinical symptoms also I try these are
tragic fever dermatitis and so forth
renal disease leukopenia and so on
disease a very severe disease but the
most prevalent feature is the presence
of an anti-nuclear antibody and these
are the anti double-stranded DNA which
is highly specific for SLE with a
sensitivity of about 65 to 75 percent
the anti Smith is present in about 20-30
percent of the cases anti ribosomal P is
10 to 20 percent of the cases the entire
NP is very well associated with the
disease activity and the entire is also
seen in almost all cases of mixed
connective tissue disease now this case
shows a very stiff hand with the
stiffened hardened skin and the
connective tissue underneath
inconsistent with the system is closest
in another type of scleroderma system
extra Rudy's called limited scleroderma
also Knights crest syndrome
Cassie know this Raynaud's phenomenon it
the difficulty with swallowing due to as
a few of these motility and also it's
different hands Clara actually is seen
and also these telangiectasia on the
palm as shown on the picture in
scleroderma limited scleroderma the most
common antibodies include anti
centromere antibody also
and diocese SCR 70 kilo Dalton kinetic
or anybody on top of I so Mary's
antibody this end he only has 30 35
percent sensitivity I am putting these
these numbers here because this is
really important that you know what if
we would expect like in hundred percent
of the scurvy I'm okay this we would see
the antibodies that are associated with
gladden with that section not the case
this is like highly specific also the
anti you are our MP fibroin
is also an excellent antibody in the
Diagnostics of scleroderma but again
this is not like hundred percent so one
has to the Roma thought this should be
aware of it that they may or may not see
the antibodies that are associated with
specific syndrome in those cases they
really should go based on other data and
clinical judgment in polymyositis and
dermatomyositis the anti j1n decay you
in anti mi two antibodies are seen but
again the sensitivity is is kind of flow
25-30 percent for the jaw of 155 percent
for the k u k you is also seen in SLE
about 10 percent of the cases the mi tu
has sensitivity of about 2 to 20 percent
for polymyositis and dermatomyositis if
there are other antibodies which are
even less specific anti histone is
actually quite useful in drug-induced
lupus we dispense in ninety percent of
the scale is sensitivity for SLE is
about 50 percent the end time row and la
Ora cocodes also called as SSA SSB
antibodies are very useful children
syndrome with the entire own about 7 to
75 percent of the cases in the in the LA
is 60 70 % of the cases of childrens is
seen if so this association is fairly
strongly anti single-stranded DNA is not
really useful and I think it shouldn't
really be better it's not specific it is
actually just something that
in in double stranded DNA tests which
are not very good they oftentimes
measure single cella DNA and that's
really not something what you want to
have the manufacturer should take care
of the single-stranded DNA or or their
antigen that it doesn't contain
single-stranded DNA so it would not bind
single-stranded DNA in the SA because
that would give false positive results
for double-stranded DNA so taken
together using evidence based criteria
DNA is are very useful for the diagnosis
of systemic lupus systemic sclerosis
actually they are critical part of the
diagnosis for drug associated lupus
mixed connective tissue disease and
outing in hepatitis E na is also using
for monitoring or prognosticating
chauhan electronic arthritis rana
phenomenon and so much use for insurance
and polymyositis dermatomyositis however
the iya knees are not useful in
rheumatoid arthritis multiple sclerosis
thyroid disease in the in the diagnosis
of infectious diseases ITP or
fibromyalgia now this shows the problem
this slide the problem with the nei fe
the lack of standardization
discrepancies between laboratories so in
this slide there are a na results by
tighter in two laboratories and table
demonstrates that in this particular
patient cohort na titers at laboratory
one were much more likely to be positive
like as you can see in lab 2 the 78 of
the cases were negative and in level one
only nine you're out of the 101 cases
only nine were negative so left to gave
like low titers in most cases in one to
forty one 281 one to 1863
on the other hand and the first lab one
to forty one to 80 were twelve ten
thirty and they were much less that were
actually at high titer so it just
demonstrates that even between two
laboratories that very
significant discrepancies these
discrepancies also are seen on the C ap
College of American Pathologists surveys
we're on the top slide the results from
871 laboratories are shown and they were
they were all over the place from 1 to
40 to 1 to 640 and that's really a big
distribution with most commonly seen 163
63 2640 but this is a big difference
whether you read it one to forty one to
80 or over 640 in the other part of the
slide we see the most commonly used test
kit for IFA and even with the most
commonly used test kit which means that
it's all the same test was used by these
242 labs you know it was also spreading
from 1 to 42 over 1 to 640 so that's a
very big spread so automated ine IFA
evaluation systems that peer to help
this problem because these provide
automated pattern recognition and Ponta
endpoint titers they are totally walk
away and they can save a lot of time is
compared to manual IFA so it can provide
a shorter turnaround time and it
provides a classification is the pre
classification of the patterns as well
so there are several of these systems
out there one of them is fda-cleared and
the study on the system showed that most
of the samples were correctly
characterized 94% of the main antibody
patterns were recognized well and the
the system didn't miss any other the
2072 antibody positive samples that were
run on this automated IFA system in a
second study a little large study 3745
serum samples were tested with a system
and the interpretation was correct as
compared to manual microscopy in about
96 point is 9 percent of the keys
so there are authors concluded that the
automation really made a nai FA a lot
more consistent however conformation was
still necessary by you expect
technologies with this method now
another method inductor side of it speak
about this in more detail using analyzer
protocol for screening in this case the
the antigens are extracted from the
nuclei and the wells are coated with
this antigen extra and again the serum
is overlaid in there lies a plate then a
second antibody which you know can
behind it will be read with chemical
sense or color imagery and absorbance if
it's spectrophotometric with appropriate
filter and this is also a newer
technology which gained acceptance
because this is automated and the
precision and overall precision of the
method is much little usability is
better and it's fully automated easier
to train the technologist for this so
the Eliza screening assays or appear to
be more objective and precise automated
faster and also it can be around the
same dia platform as the other
serologies and it's a lot easier to
train more technologies so this
certainly leads to cost reduction which
seems to be very important in today's
task environment the your our
administrators look at cost reduction in
all areas of the laboratory in other
technologies the fluorescent be - says
where the individual antigens are bound
to different fluorescent beads of
different colors so one color is
provided by the bead itself then if the
auto antibodies bound then a second
antibody is applied and wherever there's
an auto antibody bound it will bind in
the second step so that will color
provide a second color in enabling a
full cytometry like run of the SA and
this shows the different B
which in this case is 25 different
color-coded microsphere but it can go up
to 100 technologically using illuminance
based technology and then the often the
reactions the beats are run through a
flow cell where there is an excitation
and a fluorescence readout those which
are positive will actually emit will
have two different color fluorescence so
like two fluorescent is associate two
forests and karzai associated in two
signals with the positive beats that's
what they are red now this table shows
the six different commercial multiplex
any screening kids but different
companies these several of these are FDA
approved and are available on the on the
US market so what are the issues then
what is the problem with these tests the
American College of Rheumatology
position statement still states that the
interface and ifn a test is and should
remain the gold standard for any
standard testing so hospital in
commercial laboratories that use other
essays they should specify they should
compare their tests with them with the
universe na na and also the other
in-house ene test should be run using
the different WH o iu is standard and
the laboratory should always specify the
methods utilized for the detecting the
viennese when recording results so why
change them you know if it is so clear
that the NA IFA is the gold standard and
why anybody would think about anything
else
the reasons are as I already have shown
that a nai fee is subjective
technically difficult and
labor-intensive time-consuming and has a
quite poor reproducibility so economy
would really require some different
method and this technique is a need
highly skilled the medical technologists
probably could be used elsewhere in the
wrapper
we are seeing a shortage of medical
technologies due to aging workforce and
FTE reduction in many hospitals with
laboratory system integration and people
can be easily trained more easily
trained on automated methods so we
implemented because of these reasons we
implemented the multiplex through si in
our hospital and the IFA is no longer
offered in-house but we still allow it
as a send out test based on special
order from robotologist so this test is
intended for screening of the na if the
test we have chosen and also measures 10
individual clinical development
anti-nuclear antibodies the chromatin
ribosomal PSS a SSB is miss Goren p sm
RM p SC s 70 g o1 and centromere B so we
found that it actually improved the
specificity and sensitivity we see much
shorter turnaround time and eliminated
subjectivity of interpretation we
resolve this format as A&E screen
positive or negative and the clinicians
who would like to know the details they
can further analyze the positive ene by
an M don test within 30 days of the
original ena screen so the SI is
quantitative for DNA with a wh 0
standard and the other individual s
Avadi si is a semi-quantitative also
with a number so if you consider a
change you really should evaluate the
most promising systems and find out
which is the best for you and discuss
the results of any evaluation with the
rheumatologist and work through all the
process with them discuss the case is
especially discrepant ones you should
get them involved in determining what
have order says they would like to see
and make sure you don't block the
incumbant method IV because in certain
clinical cases they're absolutely
essential
so in our validation study we run 294
patient samples we had an overall
eighty-seven point five percent
agreement redoubles to be any no i would
like to add
even if you just compare down study DNA
methods themselves you probably don't
get a much better agreement and we got
96 percent for central in 97 percent for
Java 93 percent for ribosome of B and
discrepant results were resolved with
the solo patient review and discussion
with our remote ologist so if you change
then really be prepared for hard
questions from the colleagues could you
please call it the results that i
vitalis no we really can't we cannot
translate the new quantitative numbers
to correlate it exactly we did old IFA
TARDIS so you might get some questions
usually from the same doctors if want to
swim as a week initially but I don't see
anything we have been doing it for more
than seven years and I would say they
are fairly satisfied with what we are
doing and we get only very few IFA but
very well reason the your IFA requests
from the doctors they are overall quite
happy with the technology we are doing
we have a lupus panel we have a
follow-up lupus panel which also
includes some other testing like
complement CCC for and of so
double-stranded DNA follow-up and
urinalysis
so if they order this day also your up
front they are getting the result if the
initial screen was positive we also have
a second panel a scleroderma panel and
the mid connective tissue panel with
automated DNA reflexes from the
multiplex panel now very important is
that while it is no longer available in
house there áifá if the a n is
multiplied screen doesn't correlate with
the clinical presentation or the
presence of antibodies other than those
tested in the multiplex SA for example
the fiber even anti you are our MP may
be present then the hep to IFA is
available as a send out test and the
rheumatologist our doctors know this
this is available for them because this
is this is an issue this has been an
issue on cap surveys the s it doesn't
pass
those cap surveys where anti you are you
see our mp5 and antibodies are present
so this really underscores the
importance of educating the ordering
doctors about the essay so while the
gold standard listed the IFA many
laboratories are considering modern
automated options such as E is a plaque
bead methods implementing these
technologies needs a lot of care but it
can save significant savings and
efficiencies one has to make sure to
work through the process with the remote
ologies they should be involved from the
very beginning and the lab should always
specify the methods just as the ECR and
making college of rheumatology system
warn us we should specify the methods so
the remedy should be very well aware of
the expected performance and especially
the limitations of the new SI protein
house and thank you very much I hand
over the podium to dr. Schneider
hello everyone I thank you dr. Abel for
that wonderful introduction so what I'm
going to be speaking about today is a
dr. Abel mentioned a study that we
performed in our laboratory that
compared aana testing methods on an
analytical but as well as clinical basis
so our learning objectives for my part
of the talk today is to be able to list
the methods available to the clinical
laboratory for general AMA testing and
also to describe how these different AMA
methods compare in terms of their
analytical characteristics and clinical
utility so as dr. Abel mentioned in his
talk there are several methodologies
available the primary being the
immunofluorescence assay but we also
have the newer players on the market the
enzyme immunoassay and the multiplex
immunoassay so these are the three
methods that we included in our study
the immunofluorescence assay uses the
hep to cell substrate and is generally
reported with a pattern as well as a
titer with the enzyme immunoassay we
have generally the assay format is to
use a hep 2 cell lysate and this is
generally reported as a
semi-quantitative unit value and then we
have the multiplex immunoassay which
uses individual antigens which are
coupled to separate beads and then this
is reported qualitatively as either a
positive or negative result
so when laboratories are faced with all
these different methods and their and
their drastic differences the question
generally becomes how do you determine
which a and a testing method is most
appropriate for your laboratory so the
method selection for a na testing i
think still is very controversial to
this day despite the fact that these
methods have been around for many years
primarily the controversy about method
selection is really related to the fact
that these assays often will show
limited concordance between the methods
and this has been evident on a number of
different cat proficiency testing
surveys I know our clinicians often come
to us with concern
about discrepancies between a and a
tests that were performed on their
patients using different methodologies
and then lastly there have been some
relatively high profile published case
reports which also have pointed out the
lack of concordance across some of these
methodologies so this really is what led
ultimately to the ACR position statement
that dr. Abel described which I'm just
going to highlight the one section which
basically says that a and a by IFA
should remain the gold standard for AMA
testing now that was back in 2009 so I'm
going to take you back to 2009 and
talked about a na testing that was
performed as we were performing it at
the Mayo Clinic so in 2009 we did have
an enzyme immunoassay available and this
is actually what we used as our primary
am a screening methodology we also had
an immuno fluorescence assay but this
was really only available as a send out
test and I have send out in quotations
it didn't wasn't sent to an outside
reference lab it was sent to another lab
within the Mayo facility and then we had
a multiplex immunoassay methodology
available as well
however we weren't using it as an aim a
screening test but rather we were using
it to detect the antigen specific AMAs
such as SSA SSP etc as dr. Abel
described in his presentation however at
that time we were definitely having
concerns about our AMA testing one of
the concerns was due to failed
proficiency testing surveys that were
missed by the enzyme immunoassay that
were associated with the nucleo learn on
the IFA testing but we were also getting
increasing numbers of requests from
rheumatologists to have the AMA testing
performed by the immunofluorescence
assay so this led us to do a study
because we really were were wanting to
keep our enzyme immunoassay is our
primary screening method but clearly we
were we were going up against our
rheumatologist a little bit we were
having to deal with that a see our
physician statement and so we were
trying to
figure out a way to assess really what
is that what is the utility of our of
our eliza tests so the way we designed
our study we have collected a group of
samples a thousand in total which had
been submitted to our laboratory for
clinical AMA testing and this testing as
I mentioned would have been performed by
our enzyme immunoassay we defined
several cohorts based on the a a by EIA
results and you can see the numbers here
so we tried to collect more or less
equivalent numbers in each of the
different categories we had the negative
a and a testing we had the negative AMA
testing which was the value of less than
one which I'll show you right here we
had AMA values between 1 and 2.9 which
would have been weakly positive here we
had our AMA results between three and
five point nine which we would consider
positive and then our strongly positive
results on the enzyme immunoassay which
is greater than six units again you can
see that we had essentially equivalent
numbers in those different categories we
then took those 1,000 samples and we
performed additional testing using the
hep to cell IFA methodology as well as
the multiplex immunoassay method um
using it as a screaming AMA test now we
we thought about stopping at this point
here but we decided to go one step
further in the analysis and that was to
wait our cohort based on the
distribution of AMA results and our
general testing population because all
of these cohorts up here and the numbers
of samples in those cohorts don't
represent how RNA testing is generally
performed what I mean by that is that we
don't generally see 25% of our patient
samples falling into each of these
categories we generally see about 75 to
80 percent of our general AMA testing is
negative with the remaining 20 to 25%
being distributed between weak positive
positive and strongly positive
so when we did our analysis of the
analytical and then subsequent clinical
evaluation we weighted our cohort to
represent our general testing population
so what I'm going to show you first is
just the analytical components of our
methodologies and we're starting with
our IFA results that are greater than
100 1 to 320 lighter now when we look at
this cohort of samples we find that if
we if we look in that cohort to see how
many samples were also strongly positive
on the enzyme immunoassay we find that
about 35 percent were positive strongly
positive and then another approximately
40 to 45 percent were also in the weakly
positive to moderately positive range so
generally speaking an IFA results of
greater than 3 a 1 2 3 20 tighter about
75 percent of those samples end up also
being positive on our enzyme immunoassay
but subsequent to that we would
demonstrate here that the remaining 25%
also had a negative result on the enzyme
immunoassay despite having that strongly
positive IFA results we took that again
one step further and also compared that
to the multiplex immunoassay and what
did we find there well if we look at
pate we looked at the samples that were
strongly positive on the IFA as well as
the enzyme immunoassay we find that the
vast majority almost 90 percent were
also positive on the multiplex
immunoassay with a small percent showing
up as negative but if we move to that
next category where the enzyme
immunoassay was showing only a moderate
to weak to moderate positive result we
find that actually less than half of
those samples ended up being positive on
the multiplex immunoassay the majority
actually being negative and then lastly
in our group where despite the fact that
the IFA was strongly positive where the
enzyme immunoassay was negative only
it's only a small percentage less than
10 percent of those samples were
positive on the multiflex assay whereas
the vast majority ended up to be
negative now that was in the sample set
where the IFA was a strongly positive
what happens when we look at the more
moderately positive IFA results again we
can see that in the enzyme immunoassay
where they're greater than six are
strongly positive we see only a very
small percent of samples fall into that
category but majority are falling into
the category of either being weak to
moderate positive or actually being
negative so we're seeing that very few
of the what we consider moderates a weak
positives on the IFA method are also
showing up as positive on the enzyme
immunoassay again we can correlate that
with the multiplex immunoassay as well
if we look at how many samples were
positive on the multiplex immunoassay in
samples that where the enzyme
immunoassay was a strongly positive
result we find that very few were
negative and actually most did confirm
as being positive
compare that to samples where that was
only moderately positive on the enzyme
immunoassay the vast majority end up to
be negative by the multiplex method and
only a few being positive and then we're
amending samples where the enzyme
immunoassay was negative we find that
the vast majority were also negative on
the multiplex assay and with few being
positive and then our last cohort of
samples is where we have the immuno
fluorescence assay being less than or
equal to a 1 to 40 titer which most
laboratories would be considered to be a
negative finding we find that the vast
majority of these samples were also
negative on the enzyme immunoassay
however we did find that there were a
small number of samples that were either
in the weakly positive deposit
moderately positive range and we even
found some despite being negative on the
IFA we're showing strongly positive
findings on the enzyme immunoassay and
again in this cohort the enzyme
immunoassay does correlate fairly well
with the multiplex immunoassay we find
that the majority of samples that are
negative by the enzyme immunoassay and
the IFA that did end up to also be made
on the multiplex assay although again a
small percentage of samples did show up
to be positive despite the fact that
both the IFA and the enzyme immunoassay
were negative if we look in the samples
where the enzyme immunoassay was that
moderate the weak to moderate positive
again most of them were negative on the
multiplex but about 25% she had a kind
of positive finding but then in those
samples where the enzyme immunoassay was
strongly positive despite a negative IFA
we find that none of those samples
actually it's a small number but none of
them were negative then both ended up to
be positive on the multiplex immunoassay
so overall I would say that between the
various methods we ended up having about
70 to 75 percent analytical concordance
with about 30 to 25 to 35 percent of the
samples showing a discordant result but
that's just the analytical concordance
and it doesn't tell us much about
clinical utility so we had that same
group of samples that we had defined
based on their AI a result we'd
performed that additional testing we
weighted based on our normal testing
population but then again we took that
next step which was to obtain diagnostic
information through chart review so when
we did that chart review analysis then
we did a ROC curve and what we find here
the solid line is representing the IFA
testing the dotted line is representing
the enzyme immunoassay testing and then
the single rectangle on that plot is
showing the the multiplex immunoassay
and we only have a single point on our
ROC curve for that test because it is
only a qualitative test now you probably
don't need me to tell you that the area
under the curve for the IFA and the EIA
are quite similar and you've probably
also done these statistics to tell you
that there's probably no difference
really between how the IFA and the EIA
are performing overall but the one thing
we need to appreciate is that how we how
we interpret this AMA testing is is
related to what cutoff that we end up
using what the cutoff for the laboratory
or what the cutoff for the man you
factor establishes so if we look at the
multiplex immunoassay again being a
qualitative test we really only have one
cutoff to use and when we use that
cutoff we found that the multiplex
immunoassay had a specificity of very
close to 90% with a sensitivity of about
70% now how does that compare to IFA
well again it really depends on what
cutoff you're using at a 1 to 40 tighter
for IFA we find that the specificity of
that testing is very low as dr. Abel
mentioned in his talk but the
sensitivity is quite high as we increase
the cutoff the tighter for the cutoff on
the IFA we see a subsequent increase in
specificity but the sensitivity ends up
decreasing and then if we reach that 1
to 160 titer which is what many
clinicians view as kind of a clinically
actionable result we find the
specificity is actually lower than what
we find on the multiplex immunoassay
with comparable sensitivity and then how
does this compare to the enzyme
immunoassay again if we use a relatively
low cutoff we still actually see
relatively reasonable specificity
although the sensitivity is a bit lower
than we see with IFA if we increase the
enzyme immunoassay cutoff we see that
the specificity increases with the
subsequent decrease in sensitivity and
very high unit values for the enzyme
immunoassay our specificity increases
significantly however we do see a little
bit of loss of sensitivity the other
thing we did was to try to equalize all
of the methodologies for specificity and
we started by using the multiplex
immunoassay
since that was our qualitative results
and we needed to be able to basically
compare all of the other two methods to
that methods as we couldn't bury the
specificity so our specificity was set
at approximately 90% for IFA that led to
a cut-off of 1 to 324 yeah that was a
cut-off of 1.6 units and then as I said
for the multiplex it's simply that
qualitative interpretation so what does
that mean for sensitivity then
in the end enzyme immunoassay and the
multiplex when we set our specificity at
90% they ended up showing equal
sensitivity and it ended up to be
slightly above what we see for the IFA
so our take home from this is after
adjusting for specificity we found that
the EIA and the multiplex immunoassay
have almost identical sensitivity with
the IFA having slightly reduced
sensitivity now we also took that data
and put it in the context of likelihood
ratios for the multiplex immunoassay we
find that a positive result has a fairly
reasonable likelihood ratio of a little
over 5 although the negative likelihood
ratio at zero points for approximately
is probably not sufficient to rule out a
connective tissue disease if we look at
the IFA again using the various cut-offs
we found that a 1 to 40 titer has a
pretty weak positive likelihood ratio of
around 1.7 although the negative
likelihood ratio at about 0.14 is fairly
reasonable because of that high
sensitivity but as we increase the
cutoff value we see that our positive
likelihood ratio increases to about 3
when we get to a 1 to 60 titer although
we're losing the power of the negative
likelihood ratio as that increases with
the enzyme immunoassay we actually find
that we're starting off with slightly
positive a slightly higher positive
likelihood ratios increasing from about
3.7 up to close to 15 when we have a
strongly positive enzyme immunoassay
result however we do see that the like
the negative likelihood ratios for the
enzyme immunoassay aren't quite as good
as we're able to achieve with the
immunofluorescence assay so what did
that mean for us and what did that what
did that study lead us to do as far as
AMA testing at the Mayo Clinic is
concerned at present we are still
maintaining our enzyme immunoassay and
this remains our primary screening
method we still have the
immunofluorescence assay which is
available when requested however it has
been transitioned to one of the
automated IFA platforms the doctor able
mentioned in his talk
and we also still have the multiplex
immunoassay available although we're
still you only using it for detection of
the antigen specific a mas and not as a
screening a na method so to summarize my
portion of the talk I think the
diagnostic performance of the AMA
testing if we look at IFA the EIA and
the multiplex systems I think that
overall they have very similar
diagnostic utility for evaluating
connective tissue diseases however it's
critical to understand that the
performance characteristics of these
assays are really going to vary
depending on what cutoff is used by the
laboratory for making various
interpretations and also possibly for
reflexing to additional testing we know
that the IFA can achieve maximum
sensitivity although it certainly does
that at the price of specificity in
contrast
I think our data shows that the enzyme
immunoassay and the multiplex systems
definitely have the best specificity of
all the methods but again they don't
achieve quite the highest sensitivity of
the IFA and so do we think the clinical
testing for AAS is going to converge to
a single methodology and I actually
believe this is very unlikely in the
near future and I think labs will
continue to have to deal with these
different methodologies their analytical
differences as well as their differences
in clinical performance so that ends my
portion of the talk and I just put in
the reference for the study that I had
mentioned it has been published in the
journal Applied Lab medicine and if
you're interested in more detail I
encourage you to check out that
manuscript so I thank you all for your
attention
thank you so much doctor Abel of dr.
Schneider for your presentation a quick
reminder to the audience on how to
submit questions simply type them into
the Q&A box found by clicking on the
green Q&A button on the lower left of
the presentation window before we get
started in that Q&A session we have one
final poll for you
did this webinar provide you with
helpful information that you can use in
your choice of an A and a screening
method we would appreciate your
participation so let's get started with
our audience Q&A
dialogue dr. evil the first question is
for you you described a problem with
reproducibility for a n/a IFA do a na e
ia and multiplex show the same
variability issues is that an AI effect
medically if it is therefore manually
with a human element and subjectivity of
the evaluation of the Tigers eat it is
naturally has a typo usability issue
however with the EIA or the multiple
access say we don't really see this
problem because there definitely is much
greater the with the multiplex it's
about plus minus 10% with the AI even
better between 5% the reproducibility so
the revenues basically nothing should be
dissolved committed methods they are a
lot more like clinical chemistry then
floor then manual microscopy so we don't
see this issue with automated methods
thank you so much dr. Abel this next
question is for you dr. Schneider the
ROC curve comparing a nai FA e ia and
multiplex shows similar performance
can you speak to why you think there
still remains a strong focus by many
laboratories on IFA as the right method
of screening sure so I think it's a
number of reasons I think we touched on
those a little bit in the presentation
today many rheumatologists are still
view the a a bi IFA as the as the best
methodology to use so I think that
sometimes laboratories feel the the
pressure from their clinicians and
rheumatologists to maintain that
methodology despite the fact that there
is you know more and more data out there
showing that from a clinical utility
perspective the multiplex and the enzyme
immunoassay actually have comparable
characteristics if not if not even
improved and in some areas so I do think
that is an issue there is still the
issue related to proficiency testing and
and laboratories you know if they do run
an enzyme immunoassay or a multiplex
assay and they and there's a sample in
the survey that includes one of these
more rare antigen specificities that is
not detected by the enzyme immunoassay
or the multiplex assay then the
laboratory needs to deal with you know
how to handle that as far as you know
not not detecting that and and possibly
failing that survey so that's another
another issue as well and I and I do
think that a C our position statement
definitely you know carried a lot of
weight and many laboratories have been
hesitant to go to go against the
recommendation of the American College
of Rheumatology so so I think those
aren't just a few of the reasons why
many labs have elected to stay with the
IFA method despite you many
and the limitations that we've talked
about today thank you so much dr. Abel
this next question is for you in your
opinion what is the best automated IFA
platform as we do not have an automated
IFA platform as I as I mentioned we
don't offer the IFA anymore in houses to
send out so I really cannot
unfortunately I cannot comment on it
wonderful our next question dr. Abel is
for you do the automatic automated IFA
readers address the challenges with
specificity for a and a IFA tighter
speckled patterns that's all right
that's what we had the specificity issue
was related to low titer speckled
patterns so that was fine Schneider
pointed out that the specificity is
really decided by the cutoff that's used
so it's it's not as much they related to
the automated or manual reading the
automated manual ringing that makes a
big difference with the automated
reading is much more consistent than the
manual reading by different individuals
or even by the same individual at
different times of the same specimen the
automated readers issue that yes that
issue however the specificities really
determined a lot more by the cutoff
that's used for I favor for all the
other methods so I feel it itself
doesn't it doesn't address the
specificity it
it still you know if you you you it's
except like low titer low titer
special patterns is positive then the
specific thing will be very low
thank you dr. Abel dr. Schneider this
last question is for you and again thank
you audience for your participation dr.
Schneider your laboratory offers
multiple methods for a na testing does
your lab will run the CAC survey on both
methods and the second part of that
question is how do you reconcile
divergent results thanks that's a that's
a really great question because many
labs struggle with this issue not just
for AMA testing but if they if they test
for a single analyte using multiple
methods and actually cap requires on
their proficiency testing surveys that
if you're performing one analyte on
different methodologies that you only
can use their survey for one of those
methods whatever your primary method is
so the way we handle for AMA our cat
proficiency testing is that we report to
cap our four four proficiency testing
our AMA results from the enzyme
immunoassay and then what we do after
the survey has closed we use the
remaining sample that we have to test by
the IFA methodology and then use those
results to compare to our own method
comparison as cap would do as well as
with our peer group via the IFA or the
EIA now the second part of the question
is a little more challenging how do we
reconcile those discordant results
because we know that it will happen on
occasion specifically related to the to
the methodology to the particular
antibody that's within the patient
within the cap sample we in large part
do rely on the study that we we
performed recent the one I showed you
today that data to just basically
demonstrate that even though we do see
discordant
samples that the clinical utility of our
of our AIA testing or our IFA testing we
certainly look at the titer of the
antibody and how strongly positive it is
but in addition to that for our AMA by
IFA we actually also participate in
several other proficiency testing
surveys not just with cap and so we feel
that by by challenging ourselves more
with different surveys where we're able
to kind of understand more about how our
methods are performing on a routine
basis thank you again dr. Abel dr.
Schneider for your wonderful
presentation I'd also like to thank lab
reach and our sponsor bio-rad for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's a webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through April 2018
while rod will be replying to all
further questions from our audience
members you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share this announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and thanks
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye